Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Vi voglio raccontare una storia
che è cominciata un miliardo
e duecento milioni di anni fa.
Cioè, milioncino più,
milioncino meno, eh!
E questa storia
è un po' una storia d'amore.
Solo che gli amanti sono particolari:
sono due buchi neri
che per milioni e milioni di anni
hanno girato uno attorno all'altro,
avvicinandosi pian pianino.
Milioni e milioni di anni.
Sapete, l'amore, anche tra i buchi neri,
è un po' difficile, eh!
Solo che, a un certo momento,
sono arrivati così vicini
che si sono scontrati,
e hanno formato un singolo buco nero.
E da tutto questo si è generata
una potentissima onda gravitazionale,
che ha viaggiato nel tempo e nello spazio
per anni e anni, per chilometri,
finché lo scorso settembre
è arrivata qui, sul pianeta Terra,
e noi l'abbiamo vista.
E dopo mesi e mesi e mesi
di analisi, di statistiche,
e tutto quello che volete
- e non si è dormito tanto -
abbiamo annunciato al mondo intero
che abbiamo visto
la prima onda gravitazionale.
La storia in realtà è finita qua,
però scommetto che vi ha lasciato
un po' di curiosità.
Tipo: ma questo qua,
di cosa diavolo sta parlando?
Cosa sono queste onde gravitazionali?
Allora facciamo un po' di storia,
visto che siamo qui.
Dobbiamo tornare indietro
a cento anni fa,
quando un certo personaggio,
di cui forse avete sentito parlare
- si chiamava Einstein,
se non ricordo male -
ha scritto un articolo su una cosa
che ha chiamato relatività
e su cui ha detto
un sacco di cose pazzesche.
Ha detto che gli orologi che si muovono
vanno più lenti degli orologi fermi;
che quando un oggetto è in movimento,
si contrae rispetto a quando era fermo;
che lo spazio e il tempo
parlano fra loro.
Insomma, una cosa pazzesca.
E non si è fermato qui,
perché dieci anni dopo ha anche detto
che ogni massa perturba
lo spazio che la circonda,
È veramente pazzesco.
E come vi è già stato detto,
l'anno dopo ha detto
di queste onde gravitazionali.
Ma cosa vuol dire
che la massa incurva lo spazio?
Immaginate che lo spazio
sia un tappeto elastico:
se voi camminate
sul tappeto elastico dritto,
andate dritti e non
avete nessun problema.
Ma se appoggiate una massa
su questo tappeto elastico,
il tappeto elastico si deforma,
e voi siete costretti
a seguire questa curvatura.
Allora, per esempio, prendiamo il sole
che perturba il suo elastico,
e lasciamo scorrere la Terra
sull'elastico che è curvato.
Cosa succede?
Che la Terra deve seguire la curvatura.
Un po' come quando,
se avete un vortice nell'acqua,
le navi seguono il vortice
e non riescono ad uscire.
Adesso facciamo un passettino
più avanti?
Ok, prendiamo masse
che si muovono sull'elastico.
Se le masse si muovono
anche l'elastico stesso si muove.
E questo cosa provoca?
Che non solo vicino
all'elastico siamo mossi,
ma anche lontano.
Lasciate cadere un sasso
nell'acqua, cosa succede?
Che si propagano delle onde lontano.
Ecco, allora questo elastico
che si muove continuamente
anche lontano dalle masse,
queste sono le onde gravitazionali.
Ok, abbiamo capito cosa sono.
Cosa fanno?
Be', quando arriva
un'onda gravitazionale sulla Terra
succede quello
che state vedendo nel filmato.
Fa paura, eh?
Ma perché io il 14 settembre
questa cosa non l'ho vista?
Perché voi non avete visto
il vostro vicino che faceva tutto così?
Quando passa
un'onda gravitazionale,
sostanzialmente le distanze
si comprimono e si allargano.
Ma si allargano di molto poco:
stiamo parlando di distanze inferiori
al nucleo di un atomo,
quindi cose che non si vedono
ad occhio nudo.
Allora come facciamo a vedere
quando passa un'onda gravitazionale?
Be', negli anni '60
hanno sviluppato questi rivelatori
con delle barre di alluminio.
Sostanzialmente cercavano di vedere
se le barre si allungavano o no.
L'idea era buona, però
non è che funzionasse molto bene.
Allora qualche anno dopo
hanno costruito questi cosiddetti
interferometri.
Cosa sono gli interferometri?
Be', sostanzialmente si prendono i laser
- perché usare i laser è sempre fico, no?
Allora cosa si fa?
Si prende un raggio laser
e si spara lungo due direzioni diverse.
I laser percorrono la stessa distanza.
Quando ritornano al punto d'origine,
sostanzialmente si sommano
e si annullano,
e non si vede nulla.
Ma se è passata un'onda gravitazionale,
le distanze che hanno percorso
i laser sono diverse,
e quindi non si annullano più
come prima,
ma sostanzialmente
si vede un po' di luce.
Quindi, vedendo questa luce
si può vedere l'onda.
Ok, abbiamo capito essenzialmente
come possiamo vedere queste onde,
ma che ce ne facciamo?
Allora adesso il nostro amico Fido,
che è qua dietro,
vi invita a fare un piccolo gioco.
Quando ve lo dirò, sostanzialmente
vi tapperete le orecchie
per qualche secondo.
Io alzerò la mia mano,
così almeno, quando la abbasserò,
potrete riaprire le vostre orecchie.
Siete pronti? Avete capito?
Ok?
3, 2, 1, via!
Bravissimi, bravissimi.
Adesso facciamo il secondo giochino,
perché al nostro amico piace giocare.
Adesso vi coprirete gli occhi,
e in questo momento sarà la mia bocca
a dirvi quando potrete riaprirli.
Pronti?
3, 2, 1, via!
Ecco rilassatevi, già che ci siamo.
Pensate di essere tranquilli
fuori al parco,
ci sono gli uccellini...
C'è anche una leggera brezza...
Avete il vostro fidanzato o fidanzata
che vi ha portato un picnic...
Siete pronti?
Mangiate.
Ok, potete riaprire gli occhi.
Che cosa abbiamo fatto
con tutto questo?
Beh, quando abbiamo sostanzialmente
tappato le orecchie,
abbiamo un po' visto come vedevamo
l'Universo fino ad oggi,
cioè con la luce, con gli occhi.
Questo è lo spettro visibile della luce,
però come vedete ha dei buchi:
si chiama spettro di assorbimento.
Perché?
Perché quando la luce per esempio
arriva nella nostra atmosfera,
sostanzialmente incontra idrogeno,
elio, azoto, e tutto quello che c'è.
L'idrogeno se ne prende un pezzo,
l'elio se ne prende un altro,
l'azoto un altro ancora,
e restano i buchi.
Facciamo un po' un esempio:
è come dire che spedite
una lettera a un vostro amico
e il postino ve ne cancella
qualche parola.
Bastardo...
Voi, leggete la lettera, per carità,
però qualche parola ve la siete persa.
Con la luce è la stessa cosa.
Le onde gravitazionali hanno
delle buste così fisse, ma fisse,
che nessun postino riesce ad aprirle.
Ma c'è molto di più.
Voi quando avete usato solo gli occhi,
potevate vedere un cretino
sopra il palco con la mano alzata.
Ma quando mi avete ascoltato,
forse qualcuno di voi
si è immaginato veramente
di essere in quel parco.
Le onde gravitazionali
sono un nuovo messaggero
che ci descrive l'Universo.
Ne abbiamo già parecchi: la luce visibile,
la luce infrarossa, i raggi gamma
- e tutti ci danno delle
idee nuove, idee diverse.
Quindi anche le onde gravitazionali
sono un po' il nostro modo
di sentire l'Universo,
non solo di vederlo.
Quindi ci danno qualcosa in più.
Veramente?
Si!
I buchi neri, per esempio.
Per la prima volta
abbiamo veramente sentito
il suono dei buchi neri.
Finora non potevamo vederli,
perché appunto sono neri.
Niente può arrivare dal buco nero.
Ma l'onda gravitazionale
prodotta dai buchi neri, sì.
E l'abbiamo vista.
Possiamo fermarci qui?
Potremmo, ma potremmo anche
fare di più.
Non abbiamo mica solo
i buchi neri, nell'Universo.
Ci sono anche le stelle a neutroni.
E le stelle a neutroni
sono oggetti veramente molto
più complicati di un buco nero:
l'equazione di stato,
i processi che ci sono dentro...
Quindi semplicemente dalla luce
che ci arriva dalle stelle a neutroni
sappiamo parecchio,
ma non sappiamo tutto.
Possiamo sapere di più
con le onde gravitazionali
che ci arriveranno dalle stelle
a neutroni, quando ci arriveranno.
Andiamo ancora avanti?
Perché no? Le supernovae.
Grandi esplosioni pazzesche
che accadono nell'Universo,
che producono luce, neutrini,
raggi gamma, infrarossi,
e anche onde gravitazionali.
Un altro messaggero in più
che ci spiega effettivamente
come queste esplosioni
possano avvenire.
E ultimo, ma non ultimo, il Big Bang.
Di cui sappiamo poco, molto poco,
praticamente niente
sappiamo del Big Bang.
Però dalle onde gravitazionali
del Big Bang,
potremmo scoprire i primissimi
istanti di vita dell'Universo.
Quelli che ancora non sappiamo.
Quindi, cosa facciamo?
Giochiamo!
Adesso sì che possiamo rilevare
le onde gravitazionali.
Possiamo giocare
con le onde gravitazionali.
Possiamo tornare indietro
ai processi che le hanno generate.
E possiamo scoprire un po' di più
come nell'Universo funziona l'amore.
(Applausi)